I'd say more importantly for us is actually about the EV transition because EVs today,
the uptake is happening, but they are a luxury item.
- So we've had a lot of
talk over the last few days
about the economy.
You have a very interesting lens
into the economy through
the ride share business
and the eats business.
Can you give a sense of
starting with the US,
what are you seeing actually happening
with consumer behavior?
- So the consumer from our
standpoint, remains quite strong.
Now, the lens with which
we're observing consumer spend
is obviously spend on mobility,
spend on delivery of food,
groceries, et cetera.
And I think that one of the tailwinds
that we are experiencing
is because of the switch
from spend on retail
that was happening when
everyone was at home
and going crazy and just
ordering her a bunch of stuff,
back to spend on services.
As the world is reopening,
people are going out again,
they're going to see
friends, families, et cetera.
I'd argue that's a little
more healthy spend,
but we can have a debate
about that or not.
And as a result of that
shift back to services spend,
the growth in our business
and what we are seeing in
terms of consumer spend
on a local basis is actually quite strong.
So we will NSR Q4 earnings,
but the range of bookings
growth that we got to
was 23 to 27%, that's quite robust.
And that spend is strong both
the mobility and delivery.
So it's not in one segment or the other.
We've been obviously because
of all prophecies of doom
coming up, et cetera,
taking a very careful look in
terms of our best business.
Can we segment it one way or the other?
One of the areas that
we've been focused on
is the effective
Inflation on the business.
And the effect is twofold.
One is we're seeing our
restaurant partners now
pass through increases in their cost,
service costs, food costs, et cetera.
So menu Inflation is up about eight or 9%
and that does have an effect
on unit volume, right?
The classic economics apply,
which is unit volume than is a bit slower.
So for example,
unit volume in our delivery
businesses in the single digits,
decent but single digits,
mobility business, it's double digits.
The other factor is-
- And are people ordering
like cheaper dishes
and less sided dishes and this?
- Not really.
- Okay.
- We were looking for trade down behavior
one way or the other,
but it's resulting in just
average basket sizes being up.
And unit volume not
growing quite as robustly,
again, single digits, which is fine.
Versus the mobility businesses,
which is growing in the very,
very solid double digits.
The other factor that we're seeing
as it relates to Inflation
is that about 80% of earners
who are coming onto the platform platform,
there are about 5 million
people earning on Uber
on a global basis.
80% of those who are signing up
are seeing that Inflation cost of living
had something to do with
their decision to sign up,
pay for their groceries, pay
for their expenses, et cetera.
So in that way are being a platform
that can take a little bit of a shock,
that real folks are experiencing
in terms of Inflation
that makes a platform more attractive.
And to some extent, that's a service
that we are serving in terms of society.
- And are you seeing, just quickly,
are you seeing the same in Europe?
- Does quickly mean, go faster?
- No, I don't mean that
you were verbose at all.
I thought it was a very
interesting answer.
I don't wanna spend too
long on the economy.
I wanna get into the business stuff.
- Of course.
- Europe, is that the same picture?
- Very similar.
- The picture in Europe
looks quite similar.
Business is strong.
Same thing in Latin America.
So I think the shift
from retail to services
is pretty consistent.
I think your headline or
headline that I read was
that retail spend, looked
pretty weak recently.
And again, I wouldn't
necessarily take long-term trends
out of that because we made
the mistake during the pandemic
of thinking that the retail boom was,
long term trend turned out that,
everything kind of returns to norm.
So I do think that later in
the second half of the year,
the growth should modulate
off of a very, very high base.
As services spend returns to normal
and then we'll see what happens with-
- But presumably given
the lack of experience.
You don't really know
to what extent this is
just resilience of your business
versus what the economy's doing.
- I've seen many, many times CEOs
have made predictions
based on short-term trends
and declare them as long-term trends.
Reversion to norm is a
very, very powerful force.
- So you wrote a memo in May
about being hardcore on costs
and seeing hiring as a privilege
and pushing for profitability.
Can you talk just very quickly
about the impact of that
on the business?
I mean, how has that sort
of galvanized people?
And then I gotta follow up.
- Absolutely.
We were pretty early in making that call,
thank God, in hindsight.
I saw things changing and in business,
the biggest mistakes that
I see executives make is
when they don't know what
the definition of good is.
They think they're doing a
good job, but they actually,
they're aiming for a target,
but it's the wrong target.
And the reason that I wrote that memo was
because I started seeing
what we're seeing right now,
which is interest rates coming up,
capital being pulled outta the market
and performance that was defined
as excellence in the past.
Lots of growth, who cares about profit
is performance that is described
as not good enough or
middling in our new world.
So I didn't want to,
and we're a big organization,
we organized behind plans,
lots of people working their asses off
to get to those plans.
And so the reason why
I wrote the memo was,
we are just like any company,
we had annual plans in place
and totally targets, et cetera.
And everyone is kind of
gunning hard for these targets.
And I felt like our definition of good
in terms of performance,
in terms of what our own plans were,
were no longer good enough.
And that we had to be
much tougher on costs
and we had to achieve
the same growth plans
with a lot less investment
because the world was changing,
investor expectations were changing,
as a result our expectations
would would change.
So honestly, the early reaction
like that wasn't a wonderful memo
to get from your CEO on a Sunday night.
So it kind of landed a bit
like a lead balloon, initially.
But we as a company, as a
culture that really rallies,
we talk to our teams,
the teams really rallied.
And I think our performance since then,
has been on an operating
basis really leading the pack.
And I think as we enter 2023
at least I feel we are well prepared
because we've been operating
based on the expectations
of the real world
for a longer time than
a lot of other companies
that you see are making adjustments now.
- And a lot of companies to that point
are making adjustments.
And having to lay people
off insignificant numbers.
Is your early action meant
you are gonna avoid that?
I mean, how do you see that situation?
- I certainly hope so, right.
We're not at this point planning on any
company-wide layoffs, et cetera.
It's a job of the CEO
to performance manage
people and parts of the
company all the time.
I'm always gonna be taking people out,
if there's a group or division
that's underperforming,
take people out and then if
I should reinvest those folks
or reinvest assets or marketing monies,
that's part of the everyday job of a CEO.
So we will be making
those kinds of shifts.
But the core business and the
core workforce, et cetera,
we think are well-balanced
and well positioned for the future.
I certainly hope it stays that way,
but it is a dynamic environment
and we're gonna adjust pretty quickly.
- So very broadly, the end
of the cheap money era,
you've talked about Inflation
and rising interest rates
has obviously had this massive impact
on Tech valuations and Tech in general.
How far do you think we are
through that adjustment?
- I think that the 80%
of the shock is behind us
and I think a lot of
companies you're seeing
are making that initial
adjustment to get there.
I personally think that
the markets generally are betting
on a softer fed than I see
while commodity price,
Inflation, et cetera
is definitely easing up.
We have a freight business
that's involved in transportation.
Transportation costs are coming
down pretty significantly.
I don't see service
Inflation as being transitory
and I think that it's making
its way through the system.
There's a delayed effect in
terms of Inflationary effects
through the supply chain then
all the way up to consumer
and Inflation moves
slowly through the system.
So we saw it, we were surprised by it
because we didn't see
it in the end product.
And so I think that, at
least from my standpoint,
I think the Fed's gonna
stay higher for longer.
So for companies that
are hoping for a reprieve
or companies that are hoping,
"Hey, this will be a year,
things will be better next year.
I just have to like make
it through this year,"
I think they're gonna be disappointed.
- So for those of us who aren't
sitting in Silicon Valley,
under the surface, how bad is the pain
and what are you seeing
in terms of the people,
your suppliers, people
you do business with?
- First of all, I think
it's a healthy shift
that we're going through, right?
Blue collar worker paid generally
his trailed GDP growth, et cetera.
So I think the shift
that we're going through
in terms of services. industries,
Uber drivers, couriers, et cetera,
earnings moving up at strong rates,
I think that's a healthy
shift for economy.
And yes, our economy's gonna
have to make an adjustment,
but I think it'll be a healthy adjustment
one way or the other.
- Your competitors had a rougher ride,
your main competitor.
- That's fair.
- Is there anyone that you
particularly would fear
in a consolidation type
situation coming into your market
as a competitor?
I mean, who do you kind of-
- Fear in terms of ride share?
- Of coming in and buying Lyft
and actually doing something with it?
Are there any of the big Tech operators
or people that you particularly fear
coming in and taking you on?
- Honestly, thorough,
I don't spend too much
time thinking about it
because it's a waste of time
'cause I'll get it wrong.
- Fine, okay.
So let's move on from that.
So I wanna do a quick
fire round of questions
and then we'll go on to some other stuff.
When do you expect a meaningful number
of self-driving cars in your fleet?
- Define meaningful?
- 20%.
- Oh wow.
12 to 15 years.
- 12 to 15 years.
- My sec-
- Please don't remind me.
12 to 15 years from now.
- But it seems to push out each time
someone gets asked that
question, but okay.
- Okay 15 to 20.
(audience laughs)
- Will it be a US recession?
- Yes.
- Okay.
Will NASDAQ be higher or
lower at the end of the year?
- I don't care.
- What is the biggest benefit
of having people back in the office?
- This, the reaction.
I think being back in the
office is incredibly important.
I think that hybrid is the better way,
but we've got to make
that human connection,
I missed it desperately.
So I'm trying to force
our team to come back
and some of them are happy about
it and some of them aren't.
- Is there a drawback of having
people back in the office?
- Sure, convenience,
but some parts of work aren't convenient.
That's why it's called work.
- Okay, and in terms of,
you get all of the benefit
of everyone meeting up
at the water cooler and chatting,
is there a downside to
people spending too much time
doing stuff that maybe is not so relevant?
Or is that just the positive of thing.
- No, I think it's part
of being human, right?
I actually think you
hit a nail on the head,
which is Zoom life is
very transactional, right?
It's everything is by appointment,
you start at a certain time,
you end at a certain time.
You can't have any casual encounters.
Like think about Davos,
like imagine having
Davos over Zoom, right?
It would be terrible.
And so-
- [Thorold] We did.
- This is, yeah, how was it?
- I don't think I should comment
here, but we'll chat later.
Yeah, I mean it was different.
- So it's just different.
The casual encounters and
things get done faster.
I really don't believe it
should be the only way.
So I've heard some CEOs who are like,
"Five days a week we're going back."
I don't think going back is the right way,
but I actually think
the hybrid of the two,
you get the energy in terms
of being with your team
and then being remote
for a week, totally fine.
But then you need that
connection and energy
and kind of the quick
interactions to get things done.
- And just final thing,
are you still planning a Uber
specifically designed car?
- We are working with various OEMs
to design cars for ride share.
We are by far the biggest
ride share partner out there.
So I think we will be the first partner
for whom they design, but I'd expect them,
it's in their interest to
leverage whatever platforms
that they build across a
maximum volume of rides.
But we're definitely quite interested
in talking OEMs a about
purpose built vehicles.
I'd say more importantly for us is
actually about the EV transition
because EVs today, the
uptake is happening,
but they are luxury item.
The most popular car in
the Uber fleet is a Prius.
Affordable, fuel efficient.
And so we need more affordable
Electric Vehicles out there.
That is the headline conversation
that I'm having with OEMs.
Purposeful vehicles are great.
- Okay.
You touched on drivers.
Is the shortage over, I mean,
there's obviously a lot of
talk about the tightness
in the Labor market
over the last few years,
which again was Inflationary.
You talked about the wages
coming up at the bottom,
which is a positive.
Has that mitigated significantly?
Are you still struggling to find drivers
or is that over now?
- The shortage isn't over,
but the momentum for us is
moving in the right direction.
We made a pretty fundamental pivot
in terms of our company and
our efforts to be earner first,
to be driver first, to really
focus on the driver experience
in terms of onboarding,
improving customer service.
Driver earnings are excellent,
but even giving them
visibility, for example,
to earnings drivers in the
US and many other markets
didn't know what destination
the rider was going to,
we now give them upfront destinations.
So it's not just about pay,
it's about the entire driver experience
that's resulted in driver
turnover being down 20%.
Drivers are driving more.
So driver engagement is up in the teens
we added about a million drivers.
So we're up to actually a million earners,
drivers and courier.
So we're up to 5 million
earners now on a global basis.
We're the world's largest source
of work, not just gig work.
And the momentum in terms of
our earner base is growing
because the experience is getting better.
And certainly the experience on Uber
versus our competition is
starting to create some space.
- And Inflation in terms of
the wages they need to earn.
Is that still very high.
- Driver earnings versus
driver earnings last year
significantly increased?
I think that the increases this year
are gonna mitigate someone,
but I do think drivers are gonna
earn more this coming year.
On average.
- Okay.
And to what extent does that, and again,
so this is a a a little pet peeve of mind,
but to what extent has that
better visibility for drivers
hurt the consumer experience
in terms of cancellations
and availability of rides?
has that affected the consumer appearance?
- No, it has and should
improving cancellations in that,
in the previous world,
drivers who didn't see the destination,
but then once they accepted the trip,
saw a destination that they didn't like,
they would cancel on you.
Now what we do is we
show them the destination
so that they already know
when they accept a trip.
So the cancellation is
from traffic, et cetera.
Now sometimes the result is,
and the experience is, the spinner time,
which is amount of time you
say, "I wanna get a driver."
And then when we match
you up with a driver,
that may take a little longer
and that's because the offer
may go to you, it may go to me,
it may go to a third driver
before that driver accepts,
but they're accepting with
a lot more information.
We think that's a win.
- What would it mean,
there's been a lot of talk around whether
Uber driver are employees
or should be employees
in certain countries.
What impact would it have on the business
if you had to make everyone an employee?
- Oh, it would be
terrible for the business,
would be terrible for drivers.
I think the most important
thing to understand
in terms of drivers is,
I was in Amsterdam before I came here,
94% of drivers in Amsterdam
have said that they don't
want to be employees,
in the US it's 80% of drivers
don't want to be employees.
If you want a job in this economy,
almost anywhere you
are, you can get a job.
So there's a group of people
who are self-selecting
into earnings opportunities on Uber
and or other gig economy companies
that want flexible and now increasingly
very strong earnings opportunities, right?
In the US average earnings
per utilized hours,
39 bucks an hour,
we are matching up the flexibility
of those earnings
opportunities increasingly now
with benefits,
in France, for example,
as a result of sectoral bargaining
representation by the drivers,
the minimum amount that a
driver can make on a short trip
is seven Euro 65, in the UK
they've got vacation pay,
pension benefits, et cetera.
We're having discussions with states,
governments, et cetera,
as to what those benefits can be
so that you now have an outcome,
which is the flexibility to be
able to work where you want,
when you want minimum earnings standards-
- It's quite a gray area
between employee and contractor.
There's a lot of intermediate-
- Yeah, I'd say it's
a good, it's a hybrid,
that's better than where we came from-
- And this is based on what drivers want
and what makes sense for you.
You're getting the equilibrium.
- Very much, to fully
answer your question,
in markets where we have
flipped over to employment,
because we can operate Uber
in an employment model,
about two-thirds of drivers
essentially lose the opportunity
to work on the platform.
That's a big number.
That will be a tragedy
when you're talking about 5
million earners on the platform.
- Is there ever gonna be,
I mean a lot of companies
have this a situation
where there's the American dream
of you start on the shop floor
and you end up as the CEO.
Is there ever gonna be a
situation with Uber drivers
where that career progression
inside the company is possible?
Or is it always gonna
be drivers and the rest?
- Yeah, that situation is now, so one is,
you should keep in mind that drivers,
the longer drivers drive
the more money they make
because they understand the system,
they understand, "When should I drive,
when should I not drive,
where should I go, et cetera."
And as they learn the
system, they just earn more.
It's a natural learning process.
The amount drivers make
is directly related
to their utilization on the platform
and the utilization on the
platform gets better and better
as you understand the platform.
So that's number one.
Second for us is drivers
the most loyal drivers,
the best drivers,
we now provide them free college education
through University of Phoenix.
They can get either a
degree for themselves
or for a family member.
Really cool program
that I'm the big fan of.
We've now built a program
where we've got the centers of excellence
or Greenlight hubs that essentially
are customer service centers
for riders and drivers.
We hire drivers to then
become customer service reps,
et cetera, if they do
want a full-time job.
So that's a ladder,
that moves up to customer
service, et cetera.
We then take the best of
our Greenlight agents,
customer service hub agents,
and we have classes now where
we teach them how to code.
We have had classes where we teach them
how to be sales people to
go and sell to restaurants
for Uber Eats.
So we're creating our own paths up
where if you wanna stay a driver,
you can make more and
you have certain benefits
and you have educational benefits
either for your family or
you can enter the Uber system
in a full-time manner if that's something-
- That's really interesting.
So you're not stuck as a driver.
There is a progression.
That's really-
- Yeah, I mean you've gotta
build that progression.
I think companies talk
about it, we try to do it.
- That's great.
You've been in Ukraine
just before coming here.
For a couple of days.
Can you just quickly
talk a little bit about
what you're doing on the ground
and also what have you learned
that you want to sort of put in place
as your planning for other
places around the world
where disasters happen,
where you are basically part
of the critical infrastructure
of the transportation?
So can you just give us a quick-
- Absolutely, absolutely.
It was great being on
the ground with the team.
We've been operating
in Ukraine since 2016.
We've got about 25,000 drivers in Ukraine.
And we first started with using
our transportation services
to get refugees to safety, get
them to the border of Poland.
Now we're focused on helping
doctors get to hospitals,
helping teachers get to schools.
I met some of those doctors.
I met some of those teachers.
The transportation that
we take for granted here,
they can't take for granted
when they're rockets attacks,
when there are power outages, et cetera.
The availability mass
transit is quite spotty.
We then built a really
interesting program with the UN
getting food and also
items for winter shelter,
blankets, et cetera,
where we built a private label version
of essentially the Uber
fulfillment infrastructure.
You don't want to use big
trucks, mark vans, et cetera,
to get these supplies out to NGOs
that then get them to real people in need
who've been displaced.
So we essentially have
a private label Uber,
where they can hail an Uber,
it's a private vehicle,
comes in, picks up the
stuff, or a private truck,
picks up the stuff, gets them to the NGO,
they get them out to folks
who've been displaced.
Again, I got to see one
of those NGOs at work.
Very Tech savvy, very
entrepreneurial, incredibly organized.
So for me it was really encouraging
to see the work on the ground.
We work with the Ministry of Culture
to provide transportation,
to take works of art and get
them to places of safety,
get them restored so that we can retain
these incredibly important
pieces of art and culture
in Ukraine as well.
So for me, seeing it on the
ground and most importantly,
supporting the team,
letting them know that I'm with them
and also making sure
that I send the message
to Uber employees
and hopefully broaders that
we've got to stay with Ukraine.
I went to Bucha where these
terrible atrocities happen.
When you see the pit in which
these victims were buried,
not buried, I mean, throw it into it.
It just breaks your heart.
And I think we're talking
about it here, which is great,
is that we've got to
stand behind your Ukraine.
No one knows when this war is gonna end.
And we've got to stay behind Ukraine
for as long as it takes.
Uber certainly intends to do so.
- And what have you learned in terms of,
in other countries when
unexpected things happen
particularly quickly in terms of plans
that can click into place
to facilitate some of these movement?
- The really interesting
factor in terms of Uber
and what makes it interesting
is that it's so unpredictable,
every single city in which
we operate is different.
Every single circumstance is different.
So we don't have a playbook.
The playbook is, "How can we help?"
And so with Ukraine,
it literally started with refugees
and then it just
organically went to places
that we can help.
I'm sitting down with a ton
of partner organizations
and it's just how can we
help, how can we do more?
Uber is unique in that
we're a technology company.
We've got a big scope,
we're in over 70 countries,
but we're hyper hyperlocal.
So the playbook is the teams
working with government officials
and then just being
entrepreneurial in general
and trying to help in every
single city in which we operate.
- Brilliant, thank you.
I got an email yesterday
from WEF saying that Nadella,
who was here actually earlier in the week,
was talking about the AI golden age
and that it's good for humanity.
Do you agree with that?
- Yes, there will be volatility,
but long term it'll be good for humanity.
- And what does it mean for your business?
- It's not the kind of the
Chachi PT, AI, et cetera,
but we use machine learning
extensively in our business
in terms of how we deal
with real-world situations.
If you look at Uber, the
pricing routing, et cetera
is incredibly dynamic.
And our system has to,
on a real-time basis,
adjust to everything happening locally.
There is no kind of
global model, et cetera.
But we do have these AI models
that essentially are learning
behaviors on a local basis.
So if you look at our pricing
algos, matching algos,
routing algorithms, fraud
algorithms, et cetera,
all of it is powered by
larger learning models
that continue to get better
and better and better.
So it's a pretty practical use of AI,
but it's in everything that we do.
- Okay, and when you answered
the original question,
you had to think a little bit.
- It happens sometimes.
- Yeah, it wasn't a criticism,
it what are the downsides?
I mean you obviously, there's
obviously a balance in there.
I mean, what do you see
as the risk, technology?
- Yeah, I think the
downsides are that, well,
I guess short term downsides
or pain could be that
there will be displacement, right?
So if you think about ChatGPT
you can imagine restaurant
menu descriptions,
restaurant descriptions
being written by AI,
the copy in terms of
email and communications
that we send to our customers,
being written by AI and being personalized
on a one-to-one basis.
The use cases are pretty
powerful right now.
When we send in email to you
thanking you for being an Uber customer,
it's a standard email.
It will be an email to you
that will be personalized, et cetera.
That standard email is run by a person.
So the applications are going to initially
put some people out of jobs.
But what happens in our economy
always on a long-term basis
than those people find other use cases
or else you may go from a copywriter
to a ChatGPT user who is
responsible for the nature
and the feel of these emails
that ultimately are written
by ChatGPT, et cetera.
So that adjustment
period can be difficult,
can be scary, et cetera.
But I think the end state's
gonna be a good one.
- We have time for, oh wow, okay.
(audience laughing)
In the front, questions was my last word,
which I didn't get to, but go for it.
- [Audience Member 1] Thank you Thorold,
Dara, you came into Uber
in a fairly tumultuous
public cultural situation.
My curiosity to you is,
as you looked at the culture of Uber,
what were the behaviors
that you wanted to retain?
What were the ones that
you wanted to change?
And I'm particularly interested
in your executive team
and how you leverage that executive team
to change the culture of Uber.
- Yeah, absolutely.
It's a great question.
The culture that I want to
retain at Uber at the time was
this is incredible entrepreneurial energy,
innovative, go get them Culture
that was always thinking about
what's the newest best way of operating.
It's incredible rally culture.
It's like, "Let's go,
we're not gonna wait for
a second, et cetera."
That that culture,
we've kept the majority of that culture
and that culture is like
second to none, I love it.
It is so much fun because people
really rally at the company
that culture was used to
be the ultimate disruptor.
In terms of disrupting the
transportation system, et cetera.
At some point the disruptor
became an incumbent
and where the company
failed was to understand
the responsibilities that
come with incumbency.
And if you are acting like a disruptor,
but you're really an incumbent,
you kind of look like a jerk, right?
And you're not taking a
responsibility seriously, et cetera.
I don't think it's because
there's anyone who was bad there,
but things were moving so quickly
that there wasn't the time
to kind of reflect and say,
"Well, what are responsibilities?"
So the changes that I made
in terms of management
actually were on the executive team
that was more responsible
for some of these factors.
I brought a new CFO, Nelson Chai,
I brought in new general counsel,
new head of HR, et cetera.
And then at the same
time the operating leads
of the company who are
kind of doing the real work
in terms of operations, the
head of mobility operations,
delivery operations, or
head of comms and marketing,
Jill Hazelbaker who's here,
like these were stars who were there,
who were at Uber before me
and hopefully will be at Uber after me.
So I think what I'm trying
to achieve with Uber
is a combination of
the newest and the old,
which is keep that
entrepreneurial energy and edge
and the ability to move incredibly fast,
but recognize the enormous
responsibility that we have
and the dialogue that, can slow us down.
Which we're an impatient group
but is very, very necessary
to make sure that ultimately when we act,
we're acting with the right intent.
And the output is that
we're doing the right thing
as a company.
- There's another, I'll go
there, there and then there.
- [Audience Member 2] Thank you.
So Uber has committed
to be net zero by 2040.
Can you get there earlier?
- We can in certain places, right?
So we have committed
to be net zero by 2030
in the US, Canada and Europe.
In London, for example, the target's 2025
and we are making progress.
For example, California now
we're at about 10%
kilometer miles being EVs,
which is pretty awesome.
Lots of Teslas in California.
In Europe it's about 8% kilometer miles
and about five times the percentage
of generally what you see
kilometer miles in Europe.
And I think that shifting the
Uber driver over drive an EV
is so much more impactful
than the average driver
because the Uber driver's driving
five to six to seven times,
the number of miles and
then the average drivers.
So this is a very, very
targeted group of people
that we should switch over
to EV as soon as possible.
The biggest blocker I talked
about are affordable EVs
and also charging
infrastructure within cities.
Most cities are putting
charging infrastructure
in the center of cities.
That's where wealthy people tend to live.
But they're not putting EV infrastructure
where many of our drivers live
and many of our drivers need it,
which is in some of the outskirts
in other neighboring areas of the city.
We are working with cities
to give them the data
to provide them with,
"Hey, here are the different areas
where you should be putting
charging infrastructure."
And we're working both
with private and public
to help shape the plans in terms
of charging infrastructure.
It's going in the right direction,
but it's gonna take a lot of effort
from a lot of people who get there.
Sure go ahead.
- [Philippe] Yes, I'm Philippe Monnier.
I representative Swiss technology provider
specialized in automotive, named WayRay,
you said before that you're talking to OEM
in order to have customized car,
especially for you ridesharing services.
If it is not secret,
can you share to which OEM you're talking,
which specific characteristic
those car will have?
- I will give the very unsanitary
answer of it is secret.
(Thorold laughs)
I'm sorry.
- [Philippe] Characteristics.
- The characteristics for ridesharing,
one is the passenger area.
Sometimes passengers facing each other.
I do think that top speeds, for example,
top speeds that many cars have
are not necessary for city driving
that's associated with ride share.
We're also talking about
purpose built vehicles
for delivery, right?
You can imagine smaller
vehicles, two-wheelers,
three wheelers that have trunk space
that that can get through traffic easier
and have a much smaller footprint
both in terms of environmental
but also traffic footprint
than let's say a car to
go and deliver groceries.
So those are the various
area we're looking at.
- So you're likely to
be more of a black cab
facing each other model, isn't it?
- That's certainly a model
that we're looking at,
but part of it is just what
are the capabilities, right?
You're not gonna have in many cities,
quite as much highway driving
than you do in the US et cetera.
That can reduce the specs
and if you reduce the specs,
you can reduce the ultimate cost.
- Final question, and I know
we don't go but the gentleman.
- [Audience Member 3] As
it would take some time
to have more Electric cars,
would you consider to have an option
allow the customer who
can not take Electric car
and then just like, would you like to tip
or would you like to offset
your carbon footprint
after they take the journey?
- So I think understanding your question,
we have the option for
riders now to take Uber Green
and to specifically request Electric cars.
And what we've seen from customers
is that customers generally
don't want to pay a premium
in terms of dollars for an Electric car,
but they are willing to pay
a premium in terms of time.
So if the average time to get a ride
is four minutes in market,
five minutes in market,
there's a segment of customers
who will wait 10 minutes
to get an Electric car,
customers tip better for Electric cars.
It just kind of works that
way, which is pretty cool.
We are looking at offsets,
but honestly we're spending more time
just changing over the fleet, right?
So offsets is certainly a
characteristic we'll look at,
but I think just spending the energy
on changing over the fleet
is the highest impact activity of the day.